just two days ago Julie feared the worst
at work as a painter and decorator she
suddenly felt very ill
I just thought I was gonna die I'll be
honest I have never been so scared in
all my life because the pain just was
crushing
Julie called 999 and was told she could
be having a heart attack she just said
to me your category one
but we haven't got any ambulances to
send out to you
so of course that frightens you even
more then because you're thinking am I
going to die in this house on my own
Julie was taken to hospital by a friend
and is currently undergoing more tests
to diagnose her condition
she knows how dangerous any delay to
diagnosis and treatment can be
her husband Mark died of cancer last
year
it's frustrating because you keep
thinking he could still be here with us
so yeah I do get angry
[Music]
ambulance response times across all
categories are the worst on record a
major problem is that less than half of
hospital patients were discharged on
time but because of a lack of access to
social care Mrs Cullen how did the talks
with health secretary go the pressure on
the NHS could intensify if a threatened
nurses strike goes ahead there have been
initial talks between the health
secretary Steve Barkley and the Royal
College of Nursing a day after
industrial action was announced more
worry for health leaders as they face a
so-called triple demick this winter of
covid flu and unprecedented Demand on
Emergency Services wherever you look the
NHS is working flat out to ensure that
we provide the best quality of care but
yes we are under pressure how worried
are you about the nurses strike and
other industrial action by hospital
staff
clearly if members of NHS staff go on
strike it will have an impact but it's
our job to minimize that impact and to
ensure we continue providing the best
possible care to patients
patients like Julie are already being
impacted and that's ahead of the
difficult winter that is expected oh
she's Josh is Sky News in central London